oh
yes yes
starting from scratch
this is what i've always dreamed about
that is a scene from the eerie classic
movie the mosquito coast
starring harrison ford and helen mirren
now turned into a new series
that's about to launch on apple tv
starting justin thoreau
the original author of the mosquito
coast is paul theroux justin's uncle
paul is a legendary american travel
writer who has a new book out
it's called under the wave at waimea set
in hawaii
its setting may be specific but the
themes are universal
this is called alihi beach alihi means a
noble
or uh it's the elite when it comes to
natural beauty and beaches
it doesn't get much better than oahu's
north shore
famous for its world-class surfing both
professional
and amateur they're learning she got up
there you go
in a couple of weeks that girl is going
to be standing on the board she'll be
doing great yeah
for the last three decades this part of
hawaii
has been home to paul theroux all the
people i talk to
are surfers i don't talk to
intellectuals i don't talk to academics
i don't talk to politicians so my whole
world
is the surfing world it's the water
world through's new book is called
under the wave at waimea named for the
famed beach just a few miles from his
home
it's about a successful but troubled
surfer involved in a deadly car accident
who in his early 60s sets off in a road
of self-discovery
for thuru it is as always gorgeous
storytelling
and not without a bit of his own journey
mixed in surfing is also a metaphor for
living
we all have a wave that we're trying to
surf in our life
divorce is a wave unemployment is a wave
so
the book is about a surfer it's also a
guy with a problem and surfing is his
way of
solving his problems one of the things i
like i really like about the book is i
mean all stories have ups and downs but
this one really does
feel like a wave that you're writing
that he's writing
i'm glad you say that because it
actually
it's a book that i started eight years
ago and in in the intervening time
i published three books so i was always
writing it with my left hand
because my heart and soul was in it paul
theroux was born
in massachusetts in 1941 and joined the
peace corps in 1963 to work in malawi
he was expelled after helping a
political opponent of the prime minister
escape
so he began teaching english in uganda
in the 1970s after moving to london
he set off on a train ride from great
britain to japan and back through russia
that became the basis for his mega best
seller the great
railway bazaar you said you sought
trains
you found passengers yeah i realized
that travel is about
meeting people hearing their stories
it's not about going to museums churches
it's actually about people who are
overlooked
and the point of writing is discover
something about yourself about the world
you must feel this as a journalist for
sure if you go to a place and you
haven't found something new
you're thinking what am i doing here and
you and you would leave you'd go to
another place and find something out
there
through his travel books he prefers the
term chronicles
have taken him to countless destinations
he's also written nearly 30 novels this
will do for the kitchen
that could be the laundry and wash house
including the mosquito coast
about a disenchanted and eccentric
american inventor who flees the country
a story originally adapted in the 1986
film starring harrison ford
oh good things go downstream mother
life is upstream
they found us and now a tv series
reimagined for the 21st century
pack one bag be ready in 10 minutes 10
minutes
it should really resonate because the
book i wrote is about a man who wants to
leave the country he said
this is not the country that i was
raised in
this is i don't recognize anything let's
let's all leave
build american ingenuity somewhere else
so they go to the jungle in honduras
you built this yes i needed a place to
work
it started off as a guest house but now
it's my office through himself never
left the u.s
permanently splitting his time between
hawaii and cape cod
beautiful but look around his writing
space and you can see it's hard to find
a man who has traveled more
new guinea skulls nepal these are from
africa
from angola i was in a a little village
in madagascar
and i said a woman said hey i said
i said what's that she said enough i
said it's an
egg i said of what a dinosaur i said
yeah okay she said this is the egg of
the giant
elephant bird so this is your turn
you're gonna you're gonna shoot that
what do you mean oh the target okay fine
outside he keeps his aim
sharp you hit it
damn right i did he's a dead child
since he does occasionally have to deal
with predators that threaten his
chickens and geese thiru has also never
been shy at taking on what he considers
another threat you've long chafed at
celebrities who feel like they can
save africa oh yeah why is that
first saving africa is is a colonial
idea that's
you know it's it's not totally
idealistic
it's you end up being mr kurtz from
heart of darkness if you do it also it's
it should be
a long-term thing um you get people
parachuting in
they don't speak the language they know
nothing about the culture they don't
realize it's a lot of different
tribal or ethnic groups in this place
and they just talk to the president
and the president of course loves to
have someone looking after
the medical or the or the education so
that he can buy a pinstripe
suit and a mercedes i think it's harmful
actually a lot of aid to africa is
harmful
it has been said that every day spent on
the water is a day not deducted from
your life
as he hits an invigorated 80 years old
through
tests that theory religiously
when he's not rowing or feeding his
beloved geese
he writes he has another new novel
already completed
and plans for two more books that's just
to start
any plans for you to stop doing this
anytime soon
people ask that what would i do
so no no no i've been doing this um
and it seems to be working fairly well
tom brady said something interesting
he said they said when are you going to
stop he said when i
suck i'm going to stop so
maybe when i start repeating myself
or writing badly maybe that they'll be a
hint
to stop but i really have no plans to
i'll tell you what he is not writing
badly right now the new one under the
wave at wyoming
is great but what a life it's to wake up
in the morning right for a while
then go rowing and spend some time at
the beach i love how he talks about
it's about discovery yeah and writing
about the overlooked
his his his glimpse into humanity is
just
well the big thing about traveling is
not going to churches and museums
they're great but it's
meeting people these places great story
yeah really good